l'accessibilité numérique un vrai défi
pour tous les pays du monde mais encore
plus pour les petits territoires comme
celui de la réunion une accessibilité
qui concerne plus particulièrement les
personnes en situation de handicap et
les personnes âgées
c'est dans ce contexte que la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de la réunion a
proposé une conférence débat sur
l'accessibilité numérique
c'est pierre raynaud de la ccit base
structures du département qui est
également président de l'association
valentin haüy qui a présenté la
problématique à tous les partenaires
présents
on sait que ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin ce sont les personnes âgées ce
seuil ce sont les personnes en situation
de handicap les personnes à mobilité
réduite puisque sur la mobilité réduite
on peut avoir envie et besoin de
travailler à distance le télétravail de
faire ses courses sur internet de faire
ses démarches en ligne alors que les
personnes valides en le choix encore
d'aller physiquement sur place ou de le
faire en ligne ou non personnes à
mobilité réduite on n'a pas toujours le
choix
l'accessibilité numérique peut ainsi
offrir aux personnes en situation de
handicap aux personnages et la
possibilité d'accéder à tous les types
de supports informatiques tous les
handicaps sont concernés visuel auditif
moteur cognitif ou encore technique
l'accessibilité numérique est l'outil et
d'aujourd'hui jeudi rêve même pas
l'outil de demain à ces routiers
d'aujourd'hui pour les personnes donc
on va dire handicapé pour les personnes
les cras moon de la réunion surtout pour
les handicapés intellectuels donc il
faut il faut arriver un langage le plus
simple possible tout le monde puisqu'on
prend à la fois aux grammy qui habitent
dans les eaux
mais c'est sûr que l'accessibilité
numérique est l'outil de joe du moi je
dis pas que ces métiers de demain pour
la jeune chambre économique du grand sud
c'est justement défi à relever car tout
reste à faire en matière d'accessibilité
numérique
l'obligation est faite aux services de
l'état aux collectivités territoriales
aux établissements publics de mettre en
place cette accessibilité
la jeune chambre économique travaille
sur plusieurs domaines pour développer
les compétences de ses membres donc le
domaine plusieurs domaines comme le
l'économie le social l'environnemental
donc vraiment et le communautaire
plusieurs domaines et le l'accessibilité
numérique à 1 intéresse la jeune chambre
dans le sens où c'est un thème qui part
encore très développée à la réunion et
nous ce que nous voulons c'est traité
sur des sujets innovants et faire de la
réunion un modèle dans dans ce domaine
également comme comme la réunion est
déjà un modèle sur d'autres domaines
comme l'énergie permettre à tous d'avoir
accès aux communications numériques tels
que définis dans la loi du 11 février
2005 beaucoup d'efforts restent à
déployer pour arriver à rendre
accessible de l'univers numérique et
plus particulièrement les sites internet
des collectivités publiques et de l'état
aujourd'hui seuls 5 % des sites internet
publics répondent à cette exigence